[Music]
my wife gave birth to a baby boy
yesterday afternoon Seth Meyers welcomes
baby number two in a pretty bizarre way
we have to go to the hospital now
congrats are in order for the late-night
talk-show host and his wife Alexi ash
who are ready are parents to
two-year-old son ash on monday meyers
shared how his wife gave birth to their
second son and no one saw it coming my
wife is saying the baby is coming the
baby is the baby is out at which point a
newly looked and then looked at me and
says the baby is out the only way I can
describe how my wife looked was she
looked like someone who was hiding a
baby in a pair of sweats so it was
totally sneak a baby on a plane at that
point the 44 year old host says their
only options to deliver were on the
floor of their apartment Lobby or the
elevator and she lied down in our lobby
and and we should sort of like created
like a semicircle around her and you
know we undressed her and the baby was
just out the head of the baby was out
this is how fast it happened i called
9-1-1 and over the course of a minute
conversation i basically said we're
about to have a baby we're having a baby
we had a baby it's definitely a dramatic
entrance into the world both members of
the new york police department and the
fire department arrived shortly after he
was born to cut the umbilical cord the
proud parents named their baby boy axel
and he's a little cutie we named him
axel because it's just a name we like
but i'm gonna tell him it's because
firemen were there when he was born
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]